wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
also welche informationen gehören in den
lebenslauf namen und adresse sehr gut
was noch wo ich älter bin ja genau wie
schulbildung quartier in deutschland auf
einem gymnasium oder eine realschule
oder wie hier die schule noch im
heimatland
dazu gehört auch der schulabschluss habt
ihr abitur oder einen anderen abschluss
schreibt es auf günther praktikums
wichtig sein die mehrzahl von praktikum
ist praktiker dass es ein lateinisches
wort
aber ja praktika sind auch wichtig dazu
gehört auch berufserfahrung
habt ihr eine ausbildung gemacht ihr
könnt auch ein auslandssemester in den
lebenslauf schreiben das ist immer gut
also deutschkenntnisse perfekt sehr
wichtig schreibt bitte unter
sprachkenntnisse alle sprachen in den
lebenslauf die ihr gelernt habt
computerkenntnisse sind auch wichtig ihr
könnt eure hobbys in den lebenslauf
schreiben aber das ist nicht unbedingt
nötig wichtig ist nur dass man sieht was
ihr gut könnt wenn ihr fragen habt dann
endlich einfach
hallo lisa mein vater und ich brauche
deine hilfe hast du zeit
ich rufe in einer halben stunde zurück